okay i was obsessed with that interview
about all the that
the skin stuff hello i'm trying to like
maintain keep myself together
i was taking notes i always talk about
how good you look
but i have not realized and like zeroed
in
on how perfect your skin is now please
don't flirt with me this is a place of
work
i'm not drew barry anymore um thank you
you know what i grew up in washington
state so like i didn't see the sun for
the first 18 years of my life
you know yeah but i i don't buy
expensive stuff i always do drugstore
stuff which is why i was so fascinated
by hiring what he was saying
i don't think you need to spend nine
billion dollars on some serum
and yet that's about what like the skin
care industry does i mean
i've never done anything to my face and
i would like to try
to not to never say never i can never
get married again that's true i'll never
get married
you mean not for real never okay now i
believe you now i believe
never but the thing that i do care about
and i do feel is still relevant
to my life is like the face and
i just i don't i don't want i know
myself
i'm a highly addictive person right
really
and i do one injection i'm gonna look
like jocelyn wildenstein by friday
plays was there a moment where you made
that decision where you're like oop
i could either go this way or that way
because i bet in like showbiz
i think because i'm so rebellious that i
saw all of that pressure and i saw all
of those women torturing themselves to
look a certain way and i thought you
miserable people
and i i just wanted to
never be afraid of what life would do to
me i probably went to too many opposite
extremes now i'm
you know boring and safe and you know
healthy
um but i would love if there was some
way
that we could let go and give in to the
ride of life a little bit more
you know we're gonna age things are
gonna go south
and it's okay and it's a part of life
and i feel more human and more
vulnerable
every year of my life but i also know
how to appreciate every year more and
more too
and i'm a little crazy so let's get into
the news
all right now ross i know that you've
heard of
ghosting and cuffing yeah by the way
what's cuffing again
it's like cuffing season when you start
hooking up with people okay so cuffing
is like
i'm gonna put like it's arm and arm okay
it doesn't sound like that they need a
new term
okay so cuffing and couching or
cushioning ghosting all right
i want a cushion with someone i just
want to sit on a couch
well dude because cushioning sounds like
you're just hanging out on a couch but
it's very different
than that so that's what i asked okay so
cushioning
now describe cushioning well okay it's
when
it's almost like keeping multiple people
on a burner right so you're sort of with
one you're thinking about that one
but there's like three or four over here
you could like go mingle with
so there are they say there's two types
of people refinery 29 there are cuffers
who like meet a person and just kind of
want to build with that person
and then there's a cushioner someone who
has one person
that they're kind of looking at but a
bunch of different people on the back
burners oh
okay which one are you see i guess i'm
in just a
nothing did you ever do the thing where
you had a bunch of people you were
dating at one time
when i was younger yeah i was like
really into like keep it open
easy breezy stop locking everything down
stop stop stop
i was like more of a dude than a girl
yeah not
so much me no dude no here i'm like i'm
like a relationship i'm more of a girl
than a dude i was more of a dude than a
girl that explains everything that's
going on right here
i think right i tried dating a bunch of
people once and i was so exhausted
by i just know it's not for me the only
thing i would think that might be
necessary
is to try and be sort of open honest and
upfront about it like
keep it real because here's the thing
about women that you need to know
the minute we meet you we're thinking
are you the one
so i think you could do a lot of people
a favor by saying
i'm not looking for the one and i'm you
know what women are still gonna go
i'll change that's a lot of [ __ ]
yeah exactly all right next story some
people protect their hearts they do but
others need to be protecting their
password
cnn reports that get this one two three
four five six
that continues to be one of the most
used passwords online
uh also topping the list of popular
passwords password
and i love you which is sweet uh unless
unless you don't love hackers rooting
through your bank account
do you do that thing where you have nine
different passwords or do you have the
same password for every account
i have so many combinations that
unfortunately i can't get in right to
any of my stuff
so no seriously like i i can't get in
there and i don't have email i got rid
of it
sorry yep you don't have email
i don't have email i am www
at don't ever email me dot com
she's lost it
a long time ago